allow me to welcome you to the
neighborhood
[Music]
do you know the history of the house
I've been put in charge of watching you
this message will not be the last
I Am The Watcher
no this is um this story is based on a
true story
um but um we trusted the scripts we were
you know handed and of course I mean we
both read the article and
um you know from then on which was an
incredible article and so jam-packed
with Juicy
Thrills and mystery and everything but
really the the character Nora was was
there on the page and creative license
was taken for sure
I think there's someone
uh like me in a lot of uh neighborhoods
I mean the minute I read it I you know
when I read the script I thought oh my
God I no one's ever let me play Someone
Like This and um
and I I've always wanted to play someone
like that that uh you know uh I guess I
can't tip off too much but you know one
of those
very
sort of
excited friendly people in a
neighborhood
I don't know I'm too shy to be that
person or whatever but I've always
wanted to
be one even if it was on film and I got
my wish somehow I don't know how but um
but I'm very upbeat and full of energy
and
um
um
I love my job
I'm
you know and Nora's friend like Nora
gets to have a friend in this new
neighborhood so yes that yes we went to
school together we went to school at
RISD into Rhode Island art school
together so I know you know it was a you
know
a long time ago yeah we haven't seen
each other in a long time but you know I
think it's very comforting for Nora to
be in the presence of an unknown town
that you know to know someone it's yeah
and have been in control of 657
Boulevard for the better part of two
decades now
the last family turned over to you it
was their time to move on and kindly
solve it when I asked them to
657 Boulevard is my job now my life my
obsession
and now you are too branic family
welcome to the product of your greed
greed is what brought the past three
families to 657 Boulevard
yeah so I think they've worked to get to
this place for a long time this has been
something they've dreamed about and
talked about
um you know the confinement of the city
and
um wanting to be out in nature leafy
green streets and with big bedrooms and
you know that's that's something that
they've
um Wanted and so to finally get that
opportunity it's and have it in your
clutches
um it's everything that they hoped for
so
this letter while concerning is like
it's not gonna let her
um
get in the way it's we're not going to
let that get in the way of the dream
that has been fought for for so long
hi I'm Karen Calhoun from Darren Dunn
Realty this is 657 Boulevard and this is
my listing
are you ready
come on in
well yes we had the yes and and then of
course there were stages as well
um where we built rooms yes just did the
house there was the replica that was
built was so identical to the actual
house that's that I thought that was
kind of creepy I would forget which
where I was I thought that was uh just
added to How uh
how like maybe something metaphysical
was around or something because it was
just uh
uh this same sort of eerie thing and
it's it's amazing they can create an
eerie feeling just out of
building something that copies a how I
don't know it was very bizarre very
bizarre how they did that I don't know
how but I was I was creeped out in both
places
even though I knew it was a set it was
so creepy
what was he was he in the dumb waiter
yeah well my thousand apologies the last
owners let him do that he's harmless if
I find you in my house again I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up Jasper okay did you just
threaten him what is wrong with you
what's wrong with me I'm not the one
that broke into the house and started
writing the dumb waiter lady well all
the previous owners were just fine with
him doing that every owner for the past
60 years
huh I don't know I don't know
is that helpful the story did not really
go into the neighborhood that much that
I recall I mean the identity of the
neighbors and habits and so forth that I
recall I don't I don't remember that the
neighbors were uh
um so
so
that it was such a bad neighborhood that
they moved into uh in the real story I
believe it was I don't know though
Bad Neighbors
well these are about some of these are
bad neighbors
in this story I mean Ryan took
that Essence but it's all his own
imaginings beyond that of what the
neighborhood is composed of and how we
are
um our characters
yeah I believe that's all out of his
imagination
we could have been friends I got my eye
on you
if you care about your family
you're gonna get out of that house
laughs
oh I I I think
Maybe
I think so uh can we expect things with
Margot to escalate from arugula I'll
Stitch that into a sampler for you it's
really good arugula starts at a high
pitch however I do calm down and then
come back again it's it's all
I I honestly haven't seen it I haven't
even seen the first episode I wanted it
that way because I want to be surprised
and see it with the you know everybody
else when they see it so I have uh saved
it because I think it's gonna I think
I'm gonna love it that's all I hate to
break it to you Professor McGonagall but
we're actually going to be doing some
renovation in the house I'm thinking
about ripping out
the dumb ways you wouldn't dare I'll
just tell the preservation society that
uh we don't need a dumb weeder because
we plan on having our meals in the
dining room together like a normal
family you don't have to
one script at a time so we were playing
these scenes without knowing where they
were going also which was a really
interesting Journey for us as actors
that's it and I must say to working with
Margot and all of the team Jennifer
Coolidge and Naomi and Terry everyone
was is a great actor so you got these
great actors who come up to bat and hit
homers and um I love Rotten Tomatoes by
the way that's how I evaluate whether I
want to see something
um anyway yeah it was it was it was an
honor to work with all the people and
fun because if you've got people of that
caliber I don't mean to lump everyone
together but you know if you have a
person over the caliber of Margo Fritz
and you're you're in the game you're
fully in the game and it's so much fun
we really had a blast we did doing this
it was uh it was a joy to go to work I
always look forward to the days that I
was working me too
[Music]
and where do you go in the mornings
you're not going to work does your wife
know I watch her undress when you're not
there wait we jumped around with who we
thought was The Watcher
or or I would ask do you think you're
the Watcher and they go I don't know are
you the Watcher so it was yeah like
you're the one aren't you and she goes I
don't know
keeps getting them letter after letter
has no idea who's sending them it's
greed Mr Graf greed that brought you
here what do you confess to the minister
John Youngblood is what the house
desires why not just give it what
two
you'll see me in episode two just to say
hi in a hello can you look out and see
what you think of this thing she doesn't
speak like that at all um what's been
glorious is uh I get to speak my own
accent so yes you don't have to wait too
long for help to be called in and help
in the name of Theodora arrives in
episode two but it kicks in more in
episode three but her arrival is in
episode two and then a week later she
gets another letter from someone calling
themselves The Watcher
Dear Mrs Flanagan I've devoted so much
time to you I watch your house and keep
you safe
not that I know of it's an extraordinary
thing because when I was um asked to be
part of it my lovely manager Larry gave
me sent me a a link to the article I was
like oh this is creepy as f it's not I
can't imagine what that couple went
through and there's so many ideas about
what that story could be anyway but
what's great is that uh Ryan Murphy with
Ian Brennan the lead writer have created
this
story out of that story and that's what
art is great for we all have oh that's a
spark and that's always an extraordinary
spark and in the world of Murphy
Productions it's just the right amount
of creepiness and sweetness is and style
is what I feel like as well so
read it
[Applause]
I will never stop watching
it's it's it's a tool and she's working
with
um Dean uh Bobby's character Dean
brennick
um who calls her in and what I think
from very early on you realize that
Theodora has got a challenge in life and
she needs to earn
a living and
what I love what I love about Theodore
is that she loves what she does but it's
almost like an urgency and need to sort
out things in the world it's her way of
uh living is finding out stories about
people and how to solve those stories
and there's a she talks about it when
you first meet her about her drive to be
a private detective and what led her to
that space
um so that's been lovely to say in terms
of a reality in a real person because
actually you're getting this English
woman arriving who's been in America for
a very long time with an American family
and then uh but she's a private
detective which made me smile thank you
Ryan Murphy for making me private
detective I am very grateful and I will
also say Fred
the most glamorous private detective I
do believe I have met
who are you that's the job I was offered
and there was no preference in that way
it was literally and then Ryan and then
going and then we've got this character
coming in who you find is a private
detective and actually she's been
introduced by uh the cop on the four so
you'll get to meet the lovely Chris
McDonald you need to fill the house with
you what better for me
it was greed that brought your children
here once I know their names I'll call
to them
it's a growing
um when as in life when you hear
people's stories and you hear the
stories of the neighbors who hear the
stories of the relationships with the
brannex the newbies in the town and the
oldies in the town and you know it's
going to be an interesting um
excavation
of possibilities this Rogues Gallery
literally is right here surrounding them